[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana les proponemos una
reflexión apasionante a medio camino
entre la cultura y la ética se puede
admirar la obra de un artista deleznable
lo hacemos a partir del 50 aniversario
de la muerte de Picasso el año 2023 será
el año Picasso con múltiples actos aquí
en Francia y también en España para ello
nos acompañan en este estudio tres
invitadas Melissa Serrato periodista
independiente especializada en cultura
bienvenida Buenos días Carlos contamos
también con la escritora peruana en
novelista y poeta Grecia Cáceres
bienvenida Gracias
Gabriela Bravo corresponsal de Radio
Cooperativa y de culturizarte bienvenida
mucho gusto son disociables vida y obra
artística se puede admirar a alguien
deleznable socialmente hoy nuestro
asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
2023 será el año Picasso en Francia y
España con muchos acontecimientos en la
agenda cultural para conmemorar al genio
pictórico pero los ministros de cultura
de los dos países ya han dicho que no se
va a omitir la parte oscura hasta ahora
no tan afrontada del artista su maltrato
a las mujeres el programa del año
Picasso incluye 42 exposiciones en ocho
países 16 de ellas en España la eterna
pregunta sobre si es posible separar la
obra del autor volverá a llenar
titulares y copar encendidos debates no
es el primer artista ni seguramente el
último incluso nombre reputados de otros
mundos como la ciencia caso de Albert
Einstein también se han relacionado con
personalidades turbias misóginas y
déspotas quizás sea la sensibilidad del
presente lo que nos permite evaluar
muchos casos pero no me negarán que este
debate a medio camino entre la cultura y
la ética siempre despierta pasiones uno
de los últimos casos es el del rapero
kanye West consumir la música de un
declarado admirador de Hitler es inocua
algunas portadas que nos planchan este
tema revista néctard llévala la pregunta
que hoy nos hacemos a su portada hay que
separar la obra del artista en prensa
francesa ya podemos leer artículos sobre
las conmemoraciones del año Picasso con
este ángulo como lo hace la nube
Republic Picasso y las mujeres el
reverso del cuadro la revista filosofía
lleva su portada la que muchos denominan
como la cuestión de moda el woke El
Despertar se pregunta la revista si aún
podemos hablar de ciertos temas como el
racismo el género sin enfadarnos Bueno
es un debate eterno pero
apasionante al mismo tiempo coincidirán
se puede separar la obra del artista
Melisa no no absolutamente no para mí
la esta idea de la obra de arte y el
arte están a un lado de la sociedad como
una cosa que cuelga hacia un lado y
desligada totalmente es absolutamente
inconcebible el arte por el arte no es
una idea que todavía podamos asumir
Entonces yo creo que con el que podemos
tener de Quiénes son o Quiénes fueron
los personajes nuestros ídolos con los
que crecimos simplemente creo que lo que
podemos hacer hoy es mirar con
perspectiva con distancia esas obras y
entender a esos personajes que hay ahí
Pero por supuesto ni defenderlos ni
tampoco es necesario odiarlos pero sí la
mirada por supuesto cambia Grecia una
rápida ronda con la misma pregunta se
puede separar obra y artista
Bueno para mí es una pregunta muy
compleja diría sí y no porque partimos
de la biografía para ver la obra o
partimos de la obra para ver la
biografía este podemos quizá tomar una
distancia como dice Melissa histórica
para entender las circunstancias
históricas de la producción de la obra
podemos ver también la recepción de la
obra Porque esa recepcionó así en tal
época yo creo que quizás podemos
negar la obra y
más reciente quizás de de autores o
artistas que han crecido en este mundo
actual con esta mentalidad pero es
cierto que es una pregunta muy difícil y
yo misma me la me la pregunto todos los
días no Gabriela me parece también
sumamente difícil porque
es hay que saber en qué momento uno
conoce esta vida y en qué momento o sea
las obras nos han influenciado también
tanto en la música en la pintura en el
y es decir Sabemos que esta cuando las
vimos sabíamos que estas obras estaban
hechas por personas que a lo mejor
infringen incluso la ley que no no
solamente son deleznables sino que están
infringiendo la ley Entonces en ese
momento yo creo que cada uno tiene que
hacer una
introspección de qué es lo que queremos
qué es lo que queremos como sociedad qué
es lo que queremos también como arte es
esto lo que queremos queremos darle luz
a ciertos artistas dejando en la sombra
a otros Entonces es una pregunta que no
creo que tenga una sola respuesta sino
que es más bien una pregunta que nos
enfrenta a un camino
no sé si se puede tener la misma
sensibilidad os pregunto a las tres hace
una obra cuando conocemos el lado oscuro
de quien la creado es decir antes
comentaba Grecia bueno depende Si
conocemos la obra o la biografía que va
antes que va después también podemos
conocer la obra y luego el tiempo nos va
revelando detalles de la biografía pero
la obra que admirábamos ya estaba ahí
cambia esa sensibilidad del ojo del
receptor
Melissa es complicado
Por supuesto que no podemos juzgar con
los ojos de hoy
mirar con los ojos de hoy una obra del
siglo pasado de principios del siglo en
el caso de Picasso Pero lo que sí creo
es cómo vamos a pensar esa obra con
respecto a el contexto en el que vivimos
hoy hoy estamos viviendo la revolución
de las mujeres en Irán
la negación del aborto en Estados Unidos
Entonces en ese sentido yo creo que hay
que mirar también como Picasso en este
caso miraba a las mujeres las mujeres no
eran un sujeto eran simplemente el
objeto tanto de su deseo como de su
inspiración entonces también en ese
sentido entender cuál es la posición de
las mujeres en el mundo de hace de
principios del siglo y en el mundo de
hoy es totalmente diferente y también
entender que muchas mujeres hoy son las
que hacen curadurías comisarías de arte
y eso también cambia tanto la
sensibilidad como la recepción de la
obra de claro qué importante es esto no
que haya mujeres que sean curadoras
ahora de esas exposiciones de un mundo
que siempre ha sido dominado por el ojo
masculino no Grecia Sí yo creo que lo
más interesante de esta época no es
tanto el juzgar o el poner de lado
ciertas obras sino como se ha abierto la
mirada no como hemos abierto la mirada
hacia obras que habían sido que no
habían estado a la luz por ejemplo
doramar la la vuelta de doramar a la a
la a la a la Primera Plana
este y que que ha temperado un poco
también la imagen de Picasso no porque
parece ella Ella hizo todo un reportaje
fotográfico sobre guernica las fotos que
le sirvieron también a Picasso para la
obra y toda esa esta colaboración nunca
se tomaba en cuenta antes y ahora sí se
puede tomar en cuenta la colaboración
entre hombres y mujeres pero
a veces es muy doloroso también
reconocer a una obra que has admirado y
y que y que ya no puedes ver con los
mismos ojos no
poetas por ejemplo el caso de de Neruda
no Neruda que escribió su biografía
contó este este caso de de violación en
birmania y que cayó y que se publicó en
una época y Recién ahora está haciendo
olas sobre todo un país como chile tan
con tanto feminismo no con de Avanzada
claro partimos del Picasso pero ustedes
pueden ir sacando tantos ejemplos que
hay en la historia del arte de la
literatura de la música Gabriela pero
volviendo a Picasso
Picasso utilizaba a sus mujeres Entonces
su obra está íntimamente
indisociable claro No a la violencia de
género es decir su inspiración cuando
uno ve una obra no sabe nada del artista
dice bueno Esto me parece un sentimiento
tan potente Pero dónde viene a sacar esa
potencia la viene a sacar de la
violencia de aplastar a sus y de ocultar
a El Talento también de sus propias
mujeres entonces lo que yo lo que he
podido ver en esta conmemoración de
Picasso es se ha dicho que es una
celebración
en estos momentos es lo que necesita
nuestra sociedad celebrar o una persona
que está haciendo puesta en tela de
juicio por esta violencia de género y de
todo lo que se propone se propone por
ejemplo estudiar su obra El impacto que
ha tenido en la en la pintura en el arte
sin embargo no hay ninguna proposición
de el arte y la violencia de género en
la pintura de Picasso Entonces cuando
dice Vamos a abordar todos los aspectos
es verdad o lo vamos a decir Bueno es un
gran artista y le pegaba un poco a las
mujeres maltratado un poco a su señora
pero
quedémonos con este gran artista Me
parece que estamos en una época en que
tenemos que decidir
Cuál es el arte que Cuáles son los
ídolos que queremos Elevar claro los
ministros de España y Francia ya han
adelantado para decirnos que no va a
existir un tabú respecto a esta parte
oscura en la relación de Picasso con las
mujeres en el año 2023 el año Picasso
quizá esto nos demuestra que los tiempos
cambian y que celebrar a Picasso no se
puede hacer de otra de una forma
incolora o de una forma edulcorada es
decir ahora mismo los representantes
políticos Ya no les queda otra en la
sociedad actual que explicarse así no
podrían anunciar otra cosa no por
fortuna por fortuna hay que hay que
revelar esa mirada que no estaba antes y
uno mira los libros las biografías que
se han escrito de Picasso las que
conmemoran y celebran la hora de Picasso
además son en muchos casos escritas por
hombres ahora que hablaban de de doramar
hay una frase de ella que me encanta y
dice todos los retratos míos son mentira
son picassos ninguno esdor amar entonces
tenemos precisamente ese ese esa
necesidad de mirar esa otra perspectiva
que es la perspectiva femenina y yo creo
que en eso es en lo que estamos pero
cómo cómo esto es un debate sobre todo y
que plasma el Cómo cambian los tiempos
porque quién se hubiese atrevido a hacer
esta crítica hace 10 o 20 años en una
exposición de Picasso si alguien hubiera
levantado la voz para decir esto hubiera
sido ridiculizado claro la obra era Era
un objeto de admiración la no se tocaba
era Intocable era como Sagrada no Quizás
El último lugar de los sagrado es el
arte en el mundo actual entonces este se
trataba de proteger no solamente no se
hablaba sino se protegía a estas
personas y eso es lo que más lo que más
duele es cierta manera no se se les
perdonaba se les eran los grandes
hombres las grandes obras más que
marcaban el lo humano no entonces todo
eso ha cambiado mucho y eso a mí me
parece que quizás es una gran avanzada
no los grandes hombres y las grandes
obra y pero por ejemplo Bruce decía que
que no había que ver la biografía del
autor que había que ver solamente la
obra y mucha gente que es muy purista
que solamente Piensa que hay que ver la
obra y y ignorar lo que pasó con con el
autor y hay algunas las suertes que en
la Edad Media o en otras épocas no
conocíamos la biografía exacta de los
autores y hay autores hay obras que son
anónimas no entonces Quizás eso como que
te da gusto dices Bueno hay obras
anónimas pinturas anónimas y puedo
disfrutarlas sin tener que preguntarme
cómo era la vida del autor no Entonces
ese es un peso para o sea una
responsabilidad para el que recepcione
un sentido de responsabilidad en el
receptor pero estamos totalmente
totalmente sometidos a esa
responsabilidad muy pesada
responsabilidad del ojo que mira
Gabriela Sí porque es que este este
mundo del arte ha sido construido por
los hombres para los hombres y eso eso
es lo que implica todo toda esta
revisión porque
por ejemplo no solo hay que preguntarse
si un artista es del snaplo no pero
también cuántas artistas han quedado a
la sombra
Alice Alice la primera mujer
cineasta que fue completamente
ocultada de la historia del cine
completamente cuando uno ve entonces hay
que preguntarse A dónde quiero yo que
los recursos por ejemplo del Estado
vayan donde a Qué artista quiero yo
ponerle la luz a quien quiero Qué
artista también representa hay una hay
una diversidad de miradas en el arte o
esta está hecho para que cierto público
le diga a todo el mundo esto es en lo
que hay que admirar me vais a ver un
momento vamos a hacer una breve pausa
enseguida continuamos con esta edición
tan interesante de en Primera Plana
hasta ahora
[Música]
desinformación sustantivo femenino
información falsa o conjunto de acciones
que contribuyen a la desinformación del
público
en France 24 nuestro trabajo es
ofrecerles una información de calidad
nuestro rigor y nuestra independencia
nos permiten distinguir entre lo
verdadero y lo falso en los observadores
de France 24 verificamos las fotos y los
videos que circulan en internet si son
falsos se lo haremos a ver y le diremos
cómo identificarlos cada vez el mar de
la información en internet se hace más
turbulento por eso en France 24.com la
honestidad y el contexto están primero
France 24 información certificada
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes al programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo
miles de personas cada año se ven
obligadas al Éxodo a huir de sus países
en busca de una vida mejor Llevamos una
mirada humana a la migración masiva en
América Latina y en el resto del mundo
[Música]
acompáñenme en migrantes por France 24 y
France 24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana hablando del
autor y la obra a partir del caso
Picasso 2023 con Melissa Serrato
periodista independiente especializada
en cultura Gabriela Bravo corresponsal
de Radio Cooperativa y culturizarte
Grecia Cáceres escritora peruana
novelista y poeta
hay una columna del Washington post que
he leído hace pocos días la voy a leer
el conocimiento de que Woody Allen se
casó con la hermana de sus hijos y de
que es acusado de abusar a Dylan farrow
no cambia sus películas nos cambia a
nosotros mismos porque algunas de sus
tramas Antes nos parecían geniales O al
menos aceptables y ahora son incómodas
está ahí esa es incómodo ver cuando
conocemos parte de esa biografía
Gabriela exactamente
porque no puedo yo no puedo negar que
las obras de Polanski son muy buenas son
excelentes y son de una sensibilidad que
tú dices esta persona captó el alma del
ser humano de la guerra en el pianista
por ejemplo y cuando tú conoces su
biografía cuando tú sabes él es una
persona que está condenada no vamos a
decir que hay un No él él
algunas sospecha Solamente él fue
condenado en Estados Unidos y él es
prófugo de la ley entonces uno se
pregunta bueno
tengo yo voy a financiar
esta artista que tiene
que ha hecho cosas terribles y que causa
ha causado sufrimiento y que también ha
provocado que otras esta muchacha a la
que él violó que quería ser actriz Bueno
ella su carrera se acabó en ese momento
Entonces qué es lo que yo quiero
financiar qué es lo que a quién le voy a
dar por ejemplo mi visto bueno
desgraciadamente eso es un sufrimiento
para las personas que nos gusta el cine
el arte la pintura la literatura tener
que decir en un momento bueno en qué
lugar me voy a poner yo y a qué es lo
que yo quiero financiar de hecho en el
festival de Venecia de 2020 creo que fue
la Argentina la directora Argentina
lucrecia martel oficio de presidenta del
Jurado y sentó posición al saber que el
fin de Román Polanski yo acuso que es el
oficial y les pida que se tradujo Así
estaba en competencia
ella dijo que que yo no separo al hombre
del artista sentenció
una posición que se va viendo cada vez
más y luego desde el feminismo se dice
que lo de que sí que separar del hombre
del artista viene a ser un mantra no
justificativo es que yo creo que tampoco
hay que caer en esta tentación
entiendo lo que ustedes hablan por
supuesto de la responsabilidad del
espectador frente a estos personajes
pero yo creo que tampoco hay que caer en
esa tentación de negar la negación la
cancelación
a obras que nos han hablado que nos han
llegado al alma
cuidado con el tributo con el premio con
el
no hay necesidad de celebrarlo no hay
necesidad de rendirle un homenaje ciego
porque no son dioses es que son son
seres humanos Entonces como no hay
justicia y como esto se ha ido o sea
tiene que ver también con la posición de
las mujeres en esta sociedad que no
encuentran justicia Entonces es la única
herramienta que tenemos o que que tiene
el espectador es la sanción financiera
Claro pero
es injusto con uno o sea hay una especie
de de esa justicia de Ojo por ojo
te brinda también una un punto de vista
un poco difícil de mantener no decir no
voy a no voy a voy a negar el valor de
esta obra porque a mí no me no están
aprobando o no o el ojo social no no
valoriza el trabajo de las mujeres lo
que yo pienso es que hay que dar el
esfuerzo justamente el dinero el apoyo
hasta reescritura de la historia del
arte de la historia de la literatura no
que hayan más libros que se publiquen
sobre sobre las mujeres que se rescaten
las obras que han sido dejadas del lado
que hay muchísimo el caso de Octavio Paz
y Elena garro por ejemplo es un un caso
un caso muy muy importante no porque él
prácticamente prohibió escribir y es una
cosa Terrible y Octavio Paz es un Dios
es un poco como es un poco también como
Picasso no Y además como decía mirza
también por qué hacer esas
conmemoraciones porque se tiene que
hacer conmemoraciones Así bueno Yo amo a
brusco yo Estoy totalmente de acuerdo
con la conmemoración de este año de
Bruce pero esa mentalidad de conmemorar
las grandes obras los las fechas y todo
es quizá la palabra es como no es decir
bueno 2023 es el 50 aniversario de
Picasso su calidad y pictórica es
indiscutible pero cómo cómo cómo se hace
yo creo que estamos de acuerdo que el
problema es el Cómo pero parece que el
punto es que la violencia de género es
minimizada contra otro tipo de de actos
reprensibles por ejemplo un artista que
es abiertamente antisemita como Kenny
West fue inmediatamente cancelado o sea
lo sacamos de de las redes sociales para
que nos siga un poco para que no siga Sí
pero para que nos siga Entonces es eso
está claramente definido y la gente sabe
que eso es inaceptable sin embargo la
violencia de género nos parece un poco
tenemos tendencia a a hacer un poco más
cauto indulgente al momento de de
condenar porque cuando Kenny West dice
que él es admirador de Hitler es que sus
todos los sponsors todo todo el mundo se
quitó de ahí todo el mundo se fue en el
caso de Kenny West no podemos hablar de
juzgar con los ojos del pasado no
tiene una formación y una cosa que yo
creo no se puede tolerar
la obra de Picasso no podemos hacer
desaparecer la obra de Picasso y además
bueno ha habido También muchas
exposiciones de Picasso y sus maestros
todo lo que es Velázquez todo es la
todas estas grandes figuras de la
odalisca de Matiz o sea es todo Es todo
una toda una tradición pictórica de
visión de la mujer como objeto no como
sujeto que que está en juego no y que no
se puede negar y quedado obras
magníficas y que es toda una tradición
Entonces tenemos que ver todo eso en el
marco por ejemplo hay muchas obras de
Picasso que se pueden se pueden las
mujeres de argel o sea se puede se
pueden poner es una tradición queremos
que esa tradición continúe o queremos
cambiarla porque se supone que el arte
está un poco para remecer para remecer
es es la son los avangardistas que
vienen a mostrarnos un camino de seguir
Entonces estamos viendo este debate le
podemos tener ahora
cinco años yo no sé si pudiéramos saber
haberlo tenido como el arte se va a
volver un lugar de conservadurismo es es
lo que queremos o sea conservar esto que
que era lo que queríamos lo que tenemos
seguro o queremos avanzar hacia otro
tipo de arte entonces hay que ver hay
que poner hay que preguntárselo es un
lugar de conservadurismo museo está el
atesora cosas del pasado que se quedan
en una especie de temporalidad fuera
hay hay un ejemplo que yo quiero traer a
colación de la cultura totalmente
popular y es una canción de Rocío Dúrcal
que se llama vestida de blanco una mujer
virgen no es decir que llega al altar a
casarse del brazo de un hombre que me da
su nombre dice Entonces es es hoy en día
yo creo que ninguna mujer o a lo mejor
muy pocas se sentirán identificadas por
ejemplo con una canción como esa que
está en el eco y en y resuena en
nuestras cabezas porque la oyeron
nuestras madres nuestras abuelas y está
presente pero entonces también me parece
que es importantísimo ver que la no
solamente que esta mentalidad de los
hombres y del macho hay que cancelarse y
hay que negarse y hay que plantear una
nueva forma sino también ver que las
mujeres ya tenemos también otra
perspectiva y que desde esa otra
perspectiva ya miramos las cosas de otra
manera las juzgamos desde otra manera y
nos acercamos a ellas desde otra manera
entonces pongo también un otro ejemplo
de la de la cultura popular y digamos de
mi época a mí me encanta November Rain y
Sweet Child Mine de Guns n' Roses y
sabemos que Axel Rose tampoco era el
ejemplo perfecto del hombre más amoroso
ni más empático con las mujeres también
tuvo se conocen muchos casos de
violencia contra algunas de las parejas
que tuvo yo no voy a dejar de escuchar
ninguna de me fascinan y sé que
seguramente le generan dinero a Axel
Rose por la el número de escuchas en
YouTube en Spotify en deezer No sé no lo
voy a dejar de escuchar pero pero no voy
a celebrar al hombre pero pero tengo
perfectamente la conciencia
como lo planteas no escondiendo que Oye
que es que incluso contradictorio a
veces dentro de nosotros mismos o
cuestionándote a ti misma es que no
tiene que ser contradictorio es decir es
que también se hace parte de entender
que Somos humanos tanto los artistas
como nosotros Entonces en esa medida en
esa medida es que yo siento que no hay
que caer en la tendencia de la negación
ni de ni de ni de ni de negarnos a
nosotros mismos la posibilidad de seguir
disfrutando de esas obras que ya existe
estamos pasando ya a una a algo que es
estructural que es la dominación
masculina la dominación machista es una
estructura y entonces esto tampoco se
puede separar del individuo no es un
hombre que le pegó a su señora y
y hace arte y hace canciones no hay que
verlo de una manera estructural y como
estructura creo que como sociedad
necesitamos ser también responsables
entonces no es castigar a una persona es
esta estructura que hay que deshacer y
replanteársela porque es por esto que
tenemos artistas Por qué tenemos o sea
por qué Tenemos tantos artistas que que
ejercen violencia de género o que son
racistas o que son antisemitas Entonces
por qué por qué lo soportamos para mí
tiene que también las políticas públicas
ir hacia otro tipo de generar otro tipo
de arte y que inclusivos menos racista
menos antisemita y por supuesto con
menos violencia de género nombres de la
historia de mujeres que estuvieron ahí
muchas veces escondidos por supuesto es
una palabra que no hemos mencionado es
la palabra poder no este así como en la
política Hay Poder hay es un espacio de
poder el arte y la cultura también son
espacios de poder porque son personas
que van a tomar la palabra o que van a
influenciar sobre los demás Entonces es
un espacio que ha sido también que ha
tenido todos sus problemas del del
machismo y del abuso de poder no Y
entonces este y en cierta manera hasta
peor porque como que blanqueaba o sea el
hecho de ser artista te disculpaba todos
los excesos no y el hacer ser escritor
en América Latina Es así también hay
muchos hay muchos grandes artistas y
muchos grandes escritores a los que se
les ha perdonado todo no porque son
artistas y crean una obra universal y
también está la visión de del prestigio
el prestigio de la literatura el
prestigio del arte entonces todo el
mundo quiere tener un gran artista
prestigioso nadie quiere tirarlo a la
basura porque tiene una vida privada
difícil o que es prácticamente un
delincuente me quedo sin tiempo para más
ha sido apasionante hablar con ustedes
hoy Bueno lo que parece claro es que la
sociedad los valores progresan y nuestra
mirada hacia el arte va con ellos por
mucho que algunos puristas no quieran
verlo está
íntimamente asociado el límite
lógicamente lo hemos puesto es muy
complicado a veces establecerlo
Muchísimas gracias a las tres y a todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana quien en
Primera Plana gracias
[Música]